aparentemente nos llegan no solamente
tienen sables láser y poderes de la
fuerza
también la mayoría tienen una gran
cabellera y los juegos no son la sección
porque mira esas físicas perro
[Música]
ha pasado ya bastante tiempo desde el
último vídeo de detalles en videojuegos
ya que me centre un poco en otras cosas
pero ya va siendo hora de seguir con
esta serie en donde como saben le damos
un pequeño vistazo detalles en los
juegos que no siempre notamos pero que
muestran el gran esfuerzo y dedicación
con el que todos estos títulos son
hechos claro está que el hecho de que le
artes hasta el último poro a tu
personaje no afecta al juego como tal
pero vamos a es bastante impresionante
inmersivo porque no importa cuántas
veces veas un buen en totalmente
detallado bolso con físicas propias ver
ese tipo de detalles es bastante
impresionante veamos los detalles
[Música]
como sabe en este juego a medida que
progresamos en la historia tendremos la
opción de adquirir varios sables de luz
cada uno es distinto a la anterior con
los cuales destrozaremos a nuestros
enemigos pero más allá de solo cambiar
de color si tienes buen oído te darás
cuenta de que cada sable de luz tiene un
sonido distinto y único
[Música]
la bruja de blair para playstation 4 fue
un juego que pasó sin pena ni gloria a
pesar de ser de hecho bastante bueno
pero que no logró llenar las
expectativas de un hombre tan grande
como lo es la bruja de blair pero en su
juego una de las cosas buenas y curiosas
que podemos encontrar la hallamos en el
pequeño teléfono que tenemos con
nosotros en este celular podemos jugar
varios juegos de hace bastantes años
como snake y algo muy similar a space
invaders
los huevos de luego la verdad no son de
mis favoritos pero voy a decir que si
tienen bastantes cosas divertidas e
interesantes de ver en este caso en lego
star wars en cierta parte del juego
llegarás a este lugar donde podrás
encontrar a estos hombres raros tocando
algo de música ahora en los ajustes del
juego decides apagar la opción de música
harás que inmediatamente dejen de tocar
y no sepan qué hacer
[Música]
luego
y yo aguanto
[Música]
de todas todas la enorme saga que es ahí
lo sin duda alguna me gustó favoritos el
o2 tengo mucho cariño el juego recuerdo
no estábamos en el colegio que nos
escapamos para poder jugarlo por horas o
al menos hasta que nuestros papás
descubren que nos habían escapado
buenos tiempos
pero dentro de todo el tiempo que jugaba
halo 2 nunca me di cuenta un detalle que
cuando lo pienso es bastante obvio hace
poco me di cuenta de que las zonas
brillantes en los cuerpos de los comunes
el leeds de hecho indican el estado de
su escudo años jugándolo y esta ahora me
entero
muchachos son jóvenes
[Música]
en teis gone podemos encontrar algo que
se denomina clima dinámico en tiempo
real o algo así que se refiere a la
actitud y realismo con la que funcionan
las distintas condiciones climáticas es
más notorio cuando está nevando pues si
te quedas el suficiente tiempo podrás
ver como la nieve cubre el suelo y casi
todas las superficies de una manera
bastante realista con el entorno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
red dead redemption 2 es la obra maestra
del roster ya lo incluyó en los dos
vídeos anteriores y si esta serie
continúa probablemente siga apareciendo
una y otra vez porque es uno de los
nuevos más completos y detallados que
jamás haya visto puede llenar un vídeo
entero solamente con este juego algo que
me resultó fascinante es el hecho de que
dependiendo de la calidad de tus flechas
variará con qué profundidad penetrará tu
objetivo si la fecha es de mala calidad
o estado mal estado se clavara en tu
objetivo pero si las flechas de mejor
calidad lo atravesará completamente
[Música]
en el mundo de time life existen varios
tipos de zombies de los cuales los
primeros que encontraremos en los
virales o vainas que son personas que
han sido infectadas por el virus
recientemente pero que aún han sucumbido
totalmente a sus defectos y es curioso
por el hecho de que podemos notarlo
cuando los atacamos ya que en ocasiones
al no estar totalmente contagiados
muestran vestigios de su humanidad al
pedir piedad
no
mira
[Aplausos]
[Música]
south park es una gran sí y sus
videojuegos son un tanto raros tiene un
buen sentido y lo podemos notar desde el
mismo momento en el que comienza que
durante las primeras escenas del juego
trata de saltarte las cinemáticas una y
otra vez a las que karman se enoje por
interrumpirlo y esto es lo que ocurrirá
[Música]
con esta ciudad
no no te saltes esta parte es genial
no cree me quieres escuchar todo esto
usted
ya no vas a dejar de interrumpir
el crimen está fuera bien ahora estás
actuando como idiota de control hay
gatos desaparecidos
y la gente
está siendo victimizado
se oye quien se [ __ ]
mientras que está pasando
está bien está bien salta en las
cinemáticas y quieren [ __ ] de [ __ ]
durante años gears of war ha demostrado
ser una de las mejores sagas de acción
hasta la fecha contando además con
personajes muy carismáticos y mamady
ximos a la par de historias y transfondo
que hacen a los personajes grandes
compañeros a lo largo de los diversos
juegos por ejemplo en el gears of war
original ahora una parte en la que tom y
marcus tendrán esta conversación
oye marcus recuerdas las finales de la
división la línea de 40 yardas recuerdo
que me debes 20 billetes y de menos
cuando termine la guerra
cualquiera pensaría que la cosa acaba
ahí pero no pues cinco años después en
gears of war 3 podemos encontrar en la
recámara de don los 20 dólares que da
vida a marcus desde hace años
[Música]
7 a 5 es un juego enorme y al parecer
por lo visto en el anuncio de play
station 5 tendremos gta 5 hasta 2030 o
por lo menos en otras tres generaciones
de consolas pero si en un juego tan
grande es de esperarse que tenga
pequeños interesantes detalles y sí sí
que los tiene uno de ellos podemos
verlos y cuando estamos jugando con
trébol o franklin actuamos de manera
extraña cerca a la casa de michael
[Música]
o de plano la agarramos a tiros causando
que michael se enfade
[Música]
más
continuando con gta iv su inmersivo
mundo recientemente descubrí algo que me
parece genial dentro del juego y es que
si decide robar una tienda y escapas
como si nada si vuelves a la misma
tienda por segunda vez la persona a la
que robaste no estará para nada contenta
de verte
[Música]
y reyes
vida destacó
santín fuego night
[Aplausos]
de hecho pasa algo similar con mafia 2
en donde si robas una tienda o algo por
el estilo y decides volver a ese mismo
lugar habrá una cinta de policía
evidenciando que allí hubo un crimen
[Música]
al parece de robar tienen hace
supremamente divertido porque no paramos
en tiras no no lo intenten en casa de
vuelta en red dead redemption 2 ocurrirá
algo bastante parecido a lo que ya vimos
con gta iv mafia 2 ya que si es y es
igualmente asaltar una tienda y no
contento con eso le da sus batallitas al
tipo de la tienda la próxima vez que
vayas al mismo lugar verás al pobre
señor como sigue cobrándose de la
golpiza que le diste
volver a vivir
y
algo bastante único de la saga farcry
que lastimosamente se ha ido perdiendo
con el tiempo es que tiene un sistema de
curación bastante único ya que en
ocasiones al curarte saltará una
animación a la que el protagonista
literalmente se cubre de distintas
heridas y que hará que una porción de tu
salud se vea restaurada y far cry 2 es
el juego que si no me equivoco tiene más
cantidad de animaciones aquí te dejo
algunas de las mejores
[Aplausos]
yo
está bien está bien lo admito dt frank
ding no es el juego que esperaba aunque
aún así es bastante bueno y cómo se fue
hue kojima claramente tiene una gran
atención al detalle y creo que uno de
los mejores ejemplos en el juego se ve
reflejado en cómo cuidas a sanz el
protagonista ya que si por alguna razón
tú y tu enorme cerebro deciden dejar a
sham sin protección en los pies o
directamente descalzo causará que a
medida que están camine se lastima
gravemente los pies siendo bastante
notoria incluso hasta el punto en que
están dejarán marcas en el suelo con la
sangre de sus pies
que te ame
[Música]
i
y
vale
amado u odiado pero sin negarle el arduo
trabajo gran esfuerzo y cariño detrás de
las topos parte dos tiras bárbara que en
cuanto historia es bastante regular y
todo eso incluso mismo es un vídeo
hablando de él porque no me había
costado el juego que de hecho
aprovecharé la oportunidad para hacer
unas aclaraciones rápidas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero al fin el juego así como tiene
bastantes cosas malas tiene también
muchísimas otras cosas buenas a las que
vale la pena resaltar ya que en serio
este es uno de los juegos más
sorprendentes a nivel técnico ya sea con
sus bellos escenarios sus impresionantes
físicas con la cuerda sus detalladas
expresiones faciales o lo que yo creo
que es uno de los detalles más
impresionantes del juego la guitarra
este juego sí que supo darle un buen uso
al panel táctil del dualshock porque las
mecánicas incluidas en la guitarra de él
y es algo simple pero increíble desde la
manera realista en que las cuerdas
vibran con cada acorde hasta el hecho de
que todos estos mismos acordes tanto en
sonido como la posición de los dedos son
muy precisos dándote la posibilidad de
con suficiente práctica tocar casi
cualquier canción
[Música]
e
y
[Música]
i
y
ah
[Música]
no
a
[Música]
ah
i
y
no
[Música]
ah
y
no
i
[Música]
aquí
y con esto cerramos la tercera parte de
detalles en videojuegos con este vídeo
es un poco más de 45 detalles
recopilados en mi canal y son vídeos que
honestamente me encanta hacer así que si
veo bastante apoyo para mí será todo un
placer continuar con la serie
además si conoces algún otro detalle que
quieres que incluya en otro vídeo como
siempre házmelo saber en los comentarios
ya por último antes de irme quiero
agradecerles a todos por el apoyo que
recibe el canal últimamente estas
últimas semanas han sido geniales todos
ustedes son asombrosos muchas gracias
hasta la próxima
[Música]